Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Une fois n'est pas coutume, cette semaine, je reçois une pote.
Elle s'appelle Émilie-Marie. Elle nous vient du sud de la France et elle va nous parler de la pansexualité, de l'homophobie ambiante et de ce que ça a été pour elle de faire son coming out dans la France catholique et intolérante.
On écoute ça tout de suite, mais d'abord, je tiens à m'excuser platement parce que la dernière fois, je vous avais promis un épisode sur l'autisme, un épisode sur lequel je travaille depuis très longtemps et qui s'annonce parfaitement glorieux.
Mais voilà, il se trouve que je suis tombé malade entre-temps et donc on a été obligé de reporter. Promis, il arrive toujours, ce sera le prochain.
Allez, on retrouve tout de suite Émilie-Marie. Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui, on passe Septante Minutes Avec Émilie-Marie.
Émilie-Marie, salut.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour les auditeurs qui ne te connaissent pas ?
Alors, je m'appelle Émilie-Marie, j'habite à Berlin, j'ai 29 ans et je travaille dans la communication numérique et print.
Voilà, dans une boîte allemande. Ça fait six ans que je suis en Allemagne. Voilà.
Six ans que t'es en Allemagne, donc t'es française, expatriée.
Exactement.
Et la raison pour laquelle on passe septante minutes ensemble aujourd'hui, ben on se connaît toi et moi, sur, sur Internet.
Et une de tes particularités, c'est que tu es pansexuelle.
Et que visiblement, ça a piqué ta curiosité.
Ouais, c'est pas uniquement le fait d'être pansexuel, c'est aussi, tu m'avais raconté un peu le contexte de ton coming out et tout ça et ça m'avait, ça m'avait interpellé.
Il y avait beaucoup de choses très, très insolites, pour employer un mot parfaitement creux. Donc voilà.
Et en plus, j'ai remarqué que les gens réagissaient en se disant : « Mais au fond, mais c'est quoi, c'est quoi la pansexualité ?
» Enfin, il y avait beaucoup de, beaucoup de questions. Et j'ai, j'ai remarqué que ouais, il y avait peut-être un sujet à développer puisque apparemment, apparemment, les gens ne savent pas ce que c'est.
Alors, est-ce que tu peux expliquer aux auditeurs, c'est quoi en fait être pan, être pansexuel ?
Alors, être pansexuel, c'est un mot assez moderne finalement, qui a été développé il y a pas si longtemps que ça. Avant, on parlait de bisexualité.
Et en fait, maintenant qu'on traite un petit peu mieux les questions de genre, est-ce qu'on est binaire ? Est-ce qu'on est non binaire ?
Donc est-ce qu'on est une femme, un homme ou rien de deux ou alors entre les deux, etc.
On a développé le mot pansexualité pour désigner les personnes qui peuvent
tomber amoureux d'une femme, d'un homme, de quelqu'un entre ou quelqu'un qui se détermine pas comme ça, mais sans que, en fait, le genre de la personne n'ait une importance.
Donc, en fait, pour faire très très simple, grosso modo, on tombe amoureux de la personne, on est attiré par une personne physiquement, mais le genre de la personne n'a absolument aucune importance.
Et c'est pas qu'on le voit pas, mais c'est que ça ne fait vraiment rien du tout, ça ne fait absolument aucune différence.
Mh. Oui. La, la réaction que je me souviens avoir observée, c'était des gens qui avaient beaucoup de mal à comprendre du coup ce que c'était la différence entre la bisexualité et la pansexualité.
Et ce que toi, ce que toi, tu nous expliques, c'est que, ben bisexuel, c'est on est attiré par deux genres, par deux sexes et que quand on est pansexuel, on comprend qu'il n'y a pas que deux genres.
Le genre n'est pas que binaire, si je comprends bien. C'est ça que tu nous dis ?
Voilà. En fait, la pansexualité, c'est un peu comme la bisexualité, mais enfin, c'est une bisexualité qui est plus inclusive en fait.
Mais il y a beaucoup de gens qui se déterminent plus comme bisexuels juste parce que la pansexualité n'est pas connue et que du coup, c'est plus facile dans la société de se déclarer bisexuel que pansexuel
et qui,
finalement, peu importe l'appellation, en fait, le, le,
on peut tomber amoureux, pas forcément d'un sexe bien précis ou d'un genre bien précis, mais vraiment d'une, d'une globalité, voilà, tous les humains.
Mh. Ok, ouais, mais ce que je trouve vraiment intéressant là-dedans, c'est qu'effectivement, on entre dans la notion de découpler le genre du sexe.
Et donc tu nous dis, ben finalement, la différence entre une personne pansexuelle et une personne bisexuelle, c'est que la personne bisexuelle va donner de l'importance au genre.
Oui, pas tout à fait en fait. Elle va pas forcément donner de l'importance au genre parce que-
Disons que ce sera un critère pour la personne bisexuelle alors que si je comprends bien, ça ne l'est pas pour une personne pansexuelle.
Oui, non, c'est pas que c'est un critère. Je peux pas trop dire plus que c'est juste de la bisexualité plus inclusive.
Parce que si je dis plus, en fait, je rentre dans des généralités qui ne sont pas du tout vraies pour la plupart des gens.
Est-ce que ça fait du sens ?
Donc c'est assez flou comme réponse.
Oui, c'est flou parce que la pansexualité, ça fait pas longtemps que ça existe et que finalement, être pansexuel, c'est presque un acte militant dans le sens où tu ne prends pas le genre des gens.
En fait, tu ne fais pas vraiment attention au,
au genre des gens. Tandis que la bisexualité, bon, c'est le terme qui regroupe tout au départ, mais
par exemple, les bisexuels, la plupart ne vont pas ou qui vont se déterminer comme bisexuels et non pansexuels,
vont être attirés par les filles, par les garçons, mais ne vont pas forcément être attirés par tout le spectre qu'il y a au milieu, les personnes qui sont non binaires, les personnes qui
ne veulent pas se déterminer comme d'un genre ou d'un autre,
les personnes qui sont entre les deux genres.
Il y a tout un spectre en fait qu'on ignore complètement dans la société. Et disons que les personnes qui se disent pansexuelles, s'identifient comme pansexuelles, font bien attention, font la démarche de ne pas ignorer ces spectres-là en fait.
D'accord. Mais du coup, je ne suis pas sûr de saisir la distinction entre la réponse que moi, je proposais et celle que tu as donnée.
Moi, ce que moi je disais, c'était, les personnes pansexuelles sont inclusives et n'ignorent personne, alors que les personnes bisexuelles vont-
En fait, il faut pas les opposer.
Faut pas les opposer.
Il faut pas opposer les personnes bisexuelles aux personnes pansexuelles. Les personnes pansexuelles, je pense,
la plupart en tout cas, de mon point de vue et de mon expérience, se sont d'abord définies comme bisexuelles avant de se définir comme pansexuelles.
Ici, ici, je parle évidemment des personnes bisexuelles non pansexuelles.
Voilà. En fait, la plupart des personnes pansexuelles, c'est comme si la pansexualité était un petit peu un, comment dire, une sorte de sous-branche de la bisexualité, on va dire.
Ouais, on comprend bien, ouais.
Et du coup, les personnes bisexuelles qui disent : « Non, moi, je me retrouve pas dans la notion de pansexualité.
» Pour la plupart, évidemment, c'est difficile de faire des généralités, mais pour la plupart, ce sera parce que ce sont des personnes qui vont être attirées
à certains moments par des hommes, à certains moments par des femmes, mais en voyant vraiment le genre de la personne.
C'est ça. Le genre va être un critère alors que ça ne le sera pas pour une personne pansexuelle.
Oui.
OK.
C'est pas mal résumé.
Ouais, mais OK, il y avait une petite ambiguïté que je comprenais pas trop, mais je crois que c'est assez clair comme ça.
Alors, est-ce qu'on peut peut-être juste revenir sur toi, Émilie-Marie. À quel âge est-ce que toi, tu t'es découverte comme pan ?
Alors, comme pansexuelle, c'était il y a pas si longtemps que ça. C'était vraiment il y a juste quelques années quand j'ai commencé--
quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser un petit peu plus à toutes les formes de sexualité, finalement, en étant dans des associations LGBT, etc., en ayant accès à ces informations-là.
Mais bisexuelle, je me suis découverte il y a bien longtemps. J'avais à peu près 16 ans.
16 ans, OK. Et comment est-ce que ça s'est passé à l'époque ?
Alors, à l'époque, j'étais en école privée catholique assez stricte et du coup, disons que c'était pas quelque chose dont on parlait.
C'était pas quelque-
Juste, école privée catholique en France ?
En France, ouais. Dans le sud de la France.
C'est quand même assez particulier en France, non ? Parce que c'est plutôt-- enfin, ici en Belgique, on a tout plein d'écoles catholiques, mais en France, il me semble que c'est assez exceptionnel.
Oui, il y a beaucoup d'écoles publiques en France et il y a seulement quelques écoles privées, finalement. C'est pas la norme d'aller en école privée.
C'est souvent un choix mûrement réfléchi. Et donc du coup, moi, mes parents m'ont mise dans une école privée catholique dans laquelle je me sentais extrêmement bien.
C'est pour ça que j'y suis restée d'ailleurs un bon nombre d'années.
Et comment est-ce que tu définirais la spécificité d'une école privée catholique par rapport à un lycée, un lycée, entre guillemets, classique français ?
Est-ce qu'il y a une certaine idéologie catholique ? Parce que forcément, quand-- si on parle dans le contexte de
l'homosexualité, de la bisexualité, de la pansexualité et que tu mets juste à côté de ça école privée catholique, on se dit : « Tiens, mais qu'est-ce que,
qu'est-ce que ça porte comme message une école privée catholique par rapport à ces valeurs-là ? »
Alors, évidemment, c'est une école où on n'est pas obligé d'être catholique, mais où on a toutes les informations à disposition et tous les moyens de devenir vraiment catholique pratiquant, si on en a envie.
Et le corps enseignant, y compris le corps éducateur, va plus ou moins tout faire pour que tu grandisses dans une atmosphère qui soit, qui soit...
comment on dit corporate en français ?
Très bien corporate.
Qui soit corporate avec les valeurs du catholicisme.
Non. C'est-- justement, avec le reste de la phrase, ça le fait un peu moins.
Bah oui.
Qu'elle soit, je sais pas, cohérente, qu'elle soit...
Oui, qui soit cohérente. Et par exemple, le, bon le fameux « Aimez-vous les uns les autres ». Par exemple, il y avait plus d'éducateurs dans la cour pour que si jamais il y avait un conflit, qu'on puisse le régler-
OK. Et vous aviez des cours de religion, alors ?
On avait des cours de religion, mais on pouvait pas choisir la religion. Évidemment, c'était que la religion catholique.
Et c'était pas vraiment des cours, c'était plus de la sensibilisation. On avait même une sœur qui était dans notre établissement.
C'est très similaire à ce que moi, j'ai connu.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Et voilà. Et on pouvait faire des stages, par exemple en maison de retraite pour, voilà, faire des bonnes actions.
On nous poussait à faire des bonnes actions, on nous donnait la possibilité en nous incitant à faire éventuellement notre baptême si on n'était pas baptisé, notre communion, première communion, profession de foi, confirmation, etc.
Et quand on est à l'école, on est de temps en temps amené à discuter de sujets de société, genre, je sais pas moi, les trucs du style...
en France, vous en aviez tout le temps quoi, les trucs sur la burqa, sur le mariage pour tous, sur tous ces trucs qui touchent un petit peu à la religion, au vivre ensemble, à la laïcité.
Comment est-ce que tu sentais un petit peu le positionnement du staff de l'école en termes de valeurs par rapport à ces sujets-là ?
Est-ce qu'on sentait que c'était vraiment très très très ancré, très à droite, très, très conservateur ou comment c'était ?
Alors en fait, c'était même pas que c'était tabou, c'était que c'était complètement inexistant comme question-
OK
...chez nous.
On parlait pas de ce qui existait en dehors de l'école.
Non. Non, non, non. Parce qu'en fait, ce qui était à l'école, pour nous, c'était la norme. C'était complètement normal d'avoir des crucifix dans les classes.
C'était complètement normal qu'il y ait une église ou une grosse chapelle dans l'école. Tout ça, c'était complètement normal, en fait.
Là où la question s'est posée, c'est quand on a eu une camarade de classe qui est arrivée dans l'école et qui, elle, était musulmane.
Et ses parents l'avaient mise dans notre école parce que justement, ils étaient d'accord avec les valeurs du catholicisme.
Ouais, c'est assez classique ici en Belgique aussi, ça, ouais.
Et bah pour nous, c'était pas classique du tout.
Parce que justement, cette jeune fille qui était dans ma classe d'ailleurs et qui était absolument adorable, voulait, devait porter le voile et la direction de mon établissement n'était absolument pas d'accord avec ça.
Du coup, elle s'est fait renvoyer, 'fin, ça a été très difficile. Elle s'est fait pas mal renvoyer de l'établissement pour quelques jours.
Elle a pas pu rentrer parce que ils regardaient à chaque fois qu'on rentrait dans l'établissement, qu'on avait une tenue adéquate, etc.
Et elle, avec son voile, elle avait pas le droit. Donc ils ont trouvé un compromis, c'était de porter un bandeau.
Ouais, classique, ouais.
Mais les parents étaient pas vraiment d'accord. Et puis il fallait vite qu'elle remette le voile à la sortie de l'école.
Du coup, 'fin bon, ça avait créé pas mal de problèmes. C'est là où j'ai commencé à me dire que finalement, le « aimez-vous les uns les autres », il était pas forcément respecté pour tout le monde.
C'est très cohérent avec ce qu'on a ici en Belgique, avec l'école catholique ici en Belgique. Yes. Et donc, comment est-ce que, donc tu as fait ton coming out dans cette école catholique-là ?
Et comment est-ce que ça s'est passé, ça ?
Ça s'est pas très très très bien passé. En fait, j'ai commencé à...
Je me connaissais pas encore vraiment mon orientation sexuelle à l'époque, mais j'ai commencé à prendre parti, à défendre des amis qui, eux, avaient leurs premiers émois homosexuels.
OK.
Et c'était extrêmement mal vu dans la cour de récréation. Et moi, je comprenais pas pourquoi ils étaient harcelés, finalement, moqués.
Bref, du coup, j'étais la seule à les soutenir, mais j'ai perdu
une très grosse partie de mes amis à cause de ça. Et au moment où j'ai découvert que, bah moi aussi, j'étais clairement pas hétérosexuelle et que clairement, j'aimais les femmes aussi et que j'étais attirée par elles,
pas en réaction contre les hommes, mais vraiment parce que j'aimais la femme avec un grand F,
bah clairement, j'ai eu pas mal de railleries, beaucoup de gens qui se sont moqués de moi, mes copines qui, du jour au lendemain, hésitaient, voire refusaient pour venir passer des soirées à la maison,
dormir dans le même lit que moi, alors qu'avant, il y avait absolument aucun problème et que je les avais ni draguées, j'avais jamais, puis ça ne me serait même pas venu à l'esprit, finalement, d'avoir quelque chose avec elles.
Oui, voilà, de la grosse incompréhension, mais je leur en veux pas parce que très clairement, je voyais que ça faisait partie de leur éducation.
Mmm, ouais.
Et en plus de ça, on avait-
Beaucoup d'ignorance de leur part.
Complètement. C'était que de l'ignorance. Et en plus de ça, c'est là où le corps éducatif n'a vraiment pas fait son travail, à mon avis, dans cette école.
On avait zéro information sur le fait même que c'était une possibilité.
Mmm-hmm.
On nous a pas dit : « C'est mal. » On nous a pas dit : « Vous allez voir, les homosexuels, c'est une perversion » ou quoi.
Absolument pas. On a juste passé sous silence absolument tout ce sujet-là. Et du coup, j'ai été vue directement comme quelqu'un de très bizarre, quelqu'un de déviant, quelqu'un, quoi, en qui on pouvait pas avoir confiance.
Ouais, c'est assez cohérent avec l'expérience que j'ai eue ici en Belgique, en école catholique aussi.
Par contre, je suis pas sûr que si j'avais été dans l'enseignement officiel, entre guillemets, laïque, je suis pas sûr que ça aurait changé.
Ça, c'est une bonne question. Faudrait que je demande.
Et est-ce que toi, tu sais si en France, les vrais gens qui vont au vrai lycée normau-, au vrai lycée normal, ils ont des cours à ce sujet-là ?
Tu sais ça ou pas ?
À l'époque, vers 2006, quand je me suis découverte, on n'avait pas de cours là-dessus. Nous, on avait seulement des cours, même dans les lycées publics, hein, on avait seulement des cours de...
C'était même pas vraiment de l'éducation sexuelle, c'était plutôt de la prévention. On était tous enfermés pendant une demi-journée dans un amphithéâtre et on nous expliquait qu'il fallait bien faire attention
et qu'il fallait pas faire sa première fois quand on n'avait pas envie et qu'il fallait toujours se protéger parce que le sida, c'est absolument horrible et on l'attrapait n'importe quand et que nous, on pouvait tomber enceinte n'importe quand.
Bon voilà, c'était à peu près le seul message qu'on avait finalement sur la sexualité. Et a priori, d'après les retours que j'ai eus de copines et copains qui étaient en établissement public, c'était pas beaucoup mieux en public.
Maintenant, en France, on a depuis très peu de temps, d'ailleurs, il y a une loi qui est passée, me semble-t-il, il y a quelques mois ou il y a même un an, peut-être, quelque chose comme ça,
je sais plus exactement, qui demande au corps enseignant, qui prévoit pour le corps enseignant des cours de sensibilisation sur les orientations sexuelles et sur les genres, les différents genres.
Et je trouve ça extrêmement bien, mais ça fait extrêmement peur de voir les,
comment les personnes que je juge un petit peu extrêmes là-dessus dans leur conservatisme, comment est-ce qu'ils ont réagi, style Manif pour tous, etc.
Quand tu vois qu'il y a un quart de page dans un manuel de biologie qui est consacré aux transidentités, où c'est déjà la fin du monde.
Ouais, ouais. Et évidemment, tu n'es plus dans cette école, mais a priori, si tu devais imaginer tes profs de SVT donner un cours à ce sujet-là,
tu penses qu'ils feraient ça bien ou tu penses qu'ils feraient ça en traînant des pieds et en rajoutant des commentaires à deux balles ?
Évidemment, je peux pas savoir exactement parce que c'est juste moi qui m'imagine comment ça aurait pu être.
Mon sentiment, ça aurait été qu'ils auraient été un petit peu influencés par les valeurs un peu conservatrices de l'école qui tenaient vraiment, 'fin qui étaient si chères à l'école en fait.
Et que du coup, peut-être que l'enseignement à ce niveau-là aurait été un petit peu moins factuel et un peu plus nuancé qu'en école publique.
Mais évidemment, c'est que des spéculations.
Ouais, ouais. Et du coup, t'étais dans cet environnement-là où les gens comprenaient pas, où t'étais très peu informée, où les gens étaient très peu informés à ce sujet-là.
Donc très peu de, 'fin, tu disais que t'avais quand même quelques camarades homos aussi. Mais gl-
Très peu, parce qu'il fallait vraiment avoir ce besoin de s'accepter et de s'assumer. Donc il fallait vraiment que ça soit très fort pour oser le faire.
Parce que finalement, t'étais dans un environnement tellement hostile à tout ça que je suis persuadée qu'il y a maintenant des gens
qui ne sont pas hétéros et qui étaient aussi dans cette école et qui ont attendu d'être partis de l'école pour oser s'assumer.
Mh, mh. Et du coup, comment est-ce que tu as réagi au moment où tu as fait ton coming out ? Comment est-ce que tu as exploré ta sexualité ?
Alors il faut savoir qu'à l'époque où j'ai découvert que j'étais attirée par les femmes, en fait, je faisais un échange franco-allemand et du coup, j'étais en Allemagne et j'ai découvert là-bas en dansant en boîte, un soir.
En regardant les femmes danser, je me suis surprise à regarder les femmes avec des étoiles dans les yeux en me disant : « Mais qu'est-ce qu'elles sont belles ».
Donc du coup, évidemment, c'est pas forcément très facile après de se développer avec cette information-là quand on n'a absolument aucune autre source d'information.
Heureusement, Internet commençait à se développer déjà à cette époque-là, même si c'était vraiment encore les débuts, finalement.
Du coup, ça s'est développé assez lentement dans la vie réelle, mais plus rapidement sur Internet. J'ai essayé d'en parler un petit peu à ma famille, à mes parents, qui n'ont absolument aucune formation, aucune information,
qui ne connaissent absolument pas le sujet et du coup, ça les rendait mal à l'aise.
Moi, j'étais adolescente, donc évidemment, j'étais déjà mal à l'aise de base, donc ça n'aidait pas. Du coup, je me suis vraiment tournée vers Internet.
J'ai cherché des réponses sur des forums, j'ai trouvé des sites de communautés lesbiennes. Et voilà, j'ai parlé avec des lesbiennes un petit peu dans la France entière.
Il y en avait même quelques-unes en Belgique.
Et c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert que non, j'étais pas malade, que oui, ça existait, que oui, c'était tout à fait possible de vivre avec et que non, ce n'était pas une tare et que non, je ne devais pas en avoir honte.
Mais ça a mis vraiment du temps pour accepter ça, parce que finalement, il y avait un
tellement gros écart entre la réalité et les informations que j'avais sur Internet que ça a été difficile d'oser assumer ça aussi dans la réalité.
OK. Donc, grâce à Internet, t'as réussi à faire des rencontres et à t'informer à ce sujet-là.
Est-ce que tu pouvais pas te tourner vers, je sais pas moi, ben ton gynéco ou vers des médecins ou quoi, pour avoir des réponses à ce niveau-là ?
Alors, je me suis tournée un tout petit peu vers mon médecin, mais il faut savoir que mon médecin de famille, c'était le médecin de famille du coup de mes parents aussi.
Bah ouais, classique.
Et que mes parents n'étaient pas du tout... En fait, c'est un ami de mes parents. Donc quand j'ai commencé à lui raconter ça, déjà, j'étais pas forcément, mes parents
sont des gens qui sont très aimants et j'ai absolument pas de problème avec ça,
mais ils comprennent pas.
Donc pour eux, c'était très bizarre et j'avais pas envie que mon médecin aille leur en parler. Ma mère m'a jamais emmenée chez le gynéco quand j'étais jeune.
Donc j'avais pas vraiment de référent médical à ce niveau-là en fait.
OK, ouais. Donc t'as vraiment ni dans ton environnement à l'école, ni dans ta famille, ni chez le médecin, t'as personne pour te guider à ce niveau-là.
Donc t'as été sur Internet.
Y avait pas vraiment non plus d'association. J'habitais à Toulon à l'époque. Toulon, c'est dans le sud de la France.
C'est une ville qui est quand même assez tournée droite et plutôt conservatrice. Du coup, c'est pas vraiment non plus l'endroit idéal pour que des minorités puissent avoir leur place, on va dire.
Ben justement, on peut parler un petit peu de, revenir un petit peu sur la relation avec tes parents. T'avais l'air de dire qu'ils étaient très ouverts d'esprit, ou pas tellement.
'Fin, c'est un peu ambigu, j'ai pas très bien compris.
Oui, alors mes parents, en fait, ils m'ont eue très tard, donc ils font vraiment partie-- en gros, mes parents, ils ont l'âge des grands-parents de beaucoup de gens de mon âge.
Ce qui fait qu'ils ont pas du tout eu les informations qu'on a maintenant sur les différentes formes de sexualité.
C'est tout juste s'ils savaient que ça existait. Bon, voilà, ils savaient que ça existait vite fait et ils avaient pas vraiment d'a priori.
Si tu veux, ils ont pas du tout une haine des homosexuels, ils ont pas du tout, ils se disent pas : « Non, c'est pas bien, c'est le péché, c'est le mal.
» Absolument pas. Mes parents, ils sont très tolérants. Ce qui fait que j'ai quand même pu leur en parler petit à petit de mon attirance pour les femmes.
Sauf que mes parents, ils ont absolument pas d'informations. Donc du coup, évidemment, la première réaction quand tu es parent, de la plupart des parents en tout cas, et que ton enfant te dit : « Papa, maman,
je suis attirée par quelqu'un qui est du même genre que moi »,
c'est : « Oh mon Dieu, qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ?
Est-ce que notre enfant a été traumatisé et on n'a pas su ? » Surtout au début d'Internet, hein, ça faisait peur, Internet.
Est-ce qu'on a raté quelque chose dans son éducation ? Est-ce que notre enfant a un problème ? Est-ce que notre enfant a un problème psychologique ?
Et ma mère m'a d'ailleurs demandé plusieurs fois et je suis même pas sûre qu'elle pense ça encore, se dit que
oui, y a des chances que j'ai eu un traumatisme psychologique inconscient qui ferait que justement j'aime, entre autres, les femmes.
Ah et d'où ça lui vient, cette idée-là ?
Pour elle, c'est pas quelque chose de naturel, finalement-
Mh.
...que d'aimer le même genre que soi, parce que c'est pas une situation qui fait que tu-- déjà, c'est pas la majorité.
Donc c'est déjà un petit peu bizarre. Et puis en plus de ça, très clairement, deux femmes ensemble, c'est pas censé forcément faire un enfant.
Enfin, pas de manière classique, en tout cas. Donc du coup, c'est quelque chose qui l'interpelle beaucoup. Et puis on entend aussi beaucoup parler dans les médias, enfin beaucoup parler.
On entend pas mal de cas dans les médias, dans les faits divers, etc. de personnes qui, par exemple, de lesbiennes qui sont devenues lesbiennes, mais parce qu'elles se sont fait, par exemple, violer par leur mari.
Donc ça découlerait d'un traumatisme. Et c'est vrai, il y en a aussi hein, qui du coup font un énorme rejet des hommes. Moi, c'est pas du tout mon cas, mais je peux comprendre que ma mère se soit posé ce genre de questions.
OK. Et du coup, est-ce que tu dirais que tu gardes des, j'allais dire des séquelles de cette, j'allais dire un rejet, mais c'est pas vraiment un rejet.
Enfin, comment est-ce que tu vois ça ?
Je suis très reconnaissante envers mes parents de ne pas m'avoir jetée dehors comme le font certains parents quand ils découvrent la sexualité de leur enfant.
Ils m'ont toujours, ils ont toujours essayé de m'écouter. J'ai toujours pu essayer de leur parler, même s'ils comprenaient pas.
Ils me le disaient clairement : « Je suis désolé, je ne comprends pas comment c'est possible, mais OK ». Mais c'est vrai que
à ce moment-là, bon, c'était aussi pendant mon adolescence, donc forcément, c'est vraiment le moment où on coupe le cordon ombilical avec ses parents.
À ce moment-là, ça a été une des choses qui a fait que j'ai vraiment un peu plus coupé le cordon avec mes parents, qui m'a vraiment beaucoup déçue d'eux, finalement.
Parce que moi qui ai été, je suis élevée comme fille unique, donc du coup, j'ai été toujours, pas glorifiée, mais limite : « Oh là là, c'est super ce que tu fais, tu travailles bien ».
En plus, j'étais très bonne à l'école, etc. Bon, j'avais l'impression que finalement, quand on sortait de ces thèmes-là, eh ben, j'étais plus aussi chouette qu'avant comme fille.
Mh.
Et ça, ça m'a vraiment fait mal et ça a été vraiment une cassure dans ma relation avec mes parents, qui va mieux maintenant, évidemment, mais c'est sûr que j'ai toujours un, voilà...
Ça reste, ça reste dans notre histoire.
Ça laisse une marque.
Ça laisse une marque, ouais.
Au-delà de, voilà, juste la prise de conscience de ton orientation sexuelle, est-ce que tu dirais que ton coming out, ça t'a apporté des choses en termes de développement personnel, d'identité, tout ça ?
Oui, bien sûr, parce qu'en fait, quand on est obligé de faire son-- enfin, quand on se sent obligé de faire son coming out, parce que c'est vital pour nous, finalement,
pas forcément de le crier sur tous les toits, mais de
se montrer comme on est et comme on a g-- oui, comme on est vraiment à l'intérieur de nous,
on est obligé de faire une introspection sur soi.
Et en faisant cette introspection sur soi, d'ailleurs, ça demande énormément de courage de se confronter à soi-même. En faisant cette introspection sur soi, on découvre des choses qu'on n'a pas forcément envie de découvrir.
On découvre nos faiblesses. On, si on fait bien le travail, on découvre aussi nos forces, mais disons que voilà, on découvre plutôt nos faiblesses. Et
ça permet de prendre énormément de recul, d'être moins dans l'affect et d'avoir une meilleure vision de,
pas forcément comment va être notre vie future, mais de quels outils et quelles forces de caractère on va devoir développer, histoire de pouvoir continuer à avancer.
Donc ça rend plus fort parce qu'on est marginalisé, parce qu'on est différent. C'est ça que tu dis ?
Mh. Vu qu'on n'est pas dans la norme, de facto, il faut se battre si on veut pas vivre caché. Moi, vivre caché, c'est pas mon truc, très clairement.
Donc du coup, j'ai été obligée de me battre, en fait. Bon, heureusement, on n'est plus, même à l'époque, c'était pas encore un temps où on se faisait brûler sur les bûchers si on disait qu'on aimait les femmes, heureusement.
Mais on entend quand même énormément de choses pas très très cool qui peuvent vraiment détruire. Et finalement,
quand on essaye justement de se construire en tant que préadulte, de trouver sa place dans la société, on est obligé de
d'être toujours prêt limite à montrer les crocs quand on veut vivre en étant soi-même et puis sans avoir honte d'être qui on est finalement.
Je suis limite contente en fait d'avoir une sexualité qui ne soit pas l'hétérosexualité parce que du coup ça m'a obligé à faire un travail sur moi-même qui m'a énormément apporté.
J'ai vraiment pris conscience de qui j'étais, j'étais obligée de
me confronter à moi-même et j'ai vraiment pris conscience de qui j'étais, où est-ce que j'allais, est-ce que j'avais ma place, qu'est-ce que je faisais ici finalement et ça m'a permis d'avoir,
de former mon caractère,
je pense de manière un peu plus rapide ou en tout cas un petit peu plus profonde, un peu plus réfléchie et internalisée finalement que
quelqu'un qui ne se poserait pas forcément toutes ces questions-là à ce moment-
Donc c'est quoi, si je comprends bien, t'es en train de dire que de manière générale, sans, on fait évidemment des grosses approximations, des grosses généralités, mais de manière générale, les personnes LGBT
qui doivent explorer leur sexualité, leur identité sexuelle, leur orientation sexuelle, qui doivent faire cette introspection,
de manière générale, ils ont plus de chances de s'explorer que les simples personnes hétérosexuelles qui ne doivent pas tellement se poser de questions.
Si je comprends bien, c'est ça que tu dis ?
C'est vraiment la bonne occasion. On est obligé de faire une énorme introspection à l'intérieur de soi pour pouvoir accepter vraiment qui on est parce que c'est tellement intime la sexualité que c'est vraiment ancré.
Qu'est-ce que t'as découvert sur, 'fin si c'est pas indiscret, qu'est-ce que t'as découvert sur toi que tu penses que t'aurais pas découvert si t'avais pas eu cette introspection liée à ta bisexualité ?
Mes forces et mes faiblesses. En fait, ce sont des choses qui, je l'espère en tout cas, j'aurais découvert à un moment donné, mais très certainement plus tard.
Là, j'ai vraiment été obligée de faire cet énorme travail sur moi-même, sur qui je suis vraiment à l'intérieur, mais d'un coup pour pouvoir continuer à me construire sur le chemin qui m'allait finalement.
Donc cette introspection que tu évoquais, c'est quelque chose que toutes les personnes LGBT traversent, connaissent ?
Non, parce qu'il y a des gens qui ont été tellement traumatisés, soit parce qu'ils ont pas réussi à s'assumer à cause de l'environnement qui n'était pas assez favorable,
ou alors parce qu'ils ont eu d'énormes traumatismes ou on sait pas
l'histoire de chacun, ça peut changer évidemment, mais il y a des gens
qui vont pas réussir vraiment à s'accepter complètement et puis à accepter que sa vie ne soit pas exactement ce que ses parents ont voulu pour eux.
Donc du coup, le schéma de vie classique pour la plupart des gens, trouver un concubin, une concubine, se marier, avoir des enfants, une maison.
Voilà, ça demande beaucoup de force intérieure quand même hein, de s'assumer comme ça. Et du coup, il y a des gens qui vont soit se rejeter soi-même, donc très clairement
essayer de complètement ignorer cette partie-là d'eux-mêmes et puis essayer de vivre une vie-
Je renvoie nos auditeurs à l'épisode sur les prêtres homosexuels.
Par exemple.
C'est une solution. Ou une non-solution plutôt.
C'est une solution. Oui, après, les prêtres, c'est quand même une vocation normalement au départ, donc c'est encore un petit peu différent.
En théorie, oui.
En théorie. Mais 'fin chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il veut évidemment, loin de moi de juger. Mais voilà, tout le monde, on est tous différents face à ça et selon aussi l'environnement dans lequel on est.
Y a des gens qui vivent dans des pays où l'homosexualité est passible de mort. Y a des lesbiennes qui vivent dans des pays où les parents les envoient dans des camps de redressement pour qu'elles ne soient plus lesbiennes.
Et dans ces camps-là, elles vont être violées tous les jours, elles vont être battues, elles vont être affamées jusqu'à ce qu'elles avouent ne plus être lesbiennes et revenir sur le droit chemin.
'Fin, on a quand même de la chance d'être dans nos pays européens, même si le mariage pour tous a été accepté et passé y a pas longtemps, pas si longtemps que ça en France et en Allemagne du moins.
Mais c'est, il y a tellement de choses tout autour finalement, alors que c'est très intime notre sexualité, notre orientation sexuelle.
Finalement, ça conditionne et ça devrait pas, mais ça conditionne vraiment beaucoup de choses autour de nous et c'est pour ça que ça fait vraiment peur de s'assumer.
Dans nos pays, c'est pas aussi horrible que dans d'autres pays où l'homosexualité est extrêmement pénalisée, mais on voit encore des discriminations à l'embauche, par exemple.
Par exemple, en France, on n'a pas le droit de faire une insémination artificielle en tant que couple de femmes, mais en tant que femme célibataire, on a le droit.
Par exemple, ce genre de choses-là. Y a encore tout plein de sujets finalement
qui sont attachés à l'homosexualité, plus ou moins visibles, ou même à la bisexualité, mais au fait voilà de ne pas avoir une sexualité très hétéronormée dans notre société très hétéronormée.
Et c'est pour ça que finalement, ça fait peur et ça demande énormément de courage. Pour revenir juste vite fait sur ma mère parce que je pense que c'est important de rajouter ça.
Ma mère en fait elle avait pas peur du fait que je sois homosexuelle, du fait que je puisse peut-être pas avoir d'enfants.
Maintenant, on sait que évidemment les lesbiennes peuvent très bien avoir des enfants. Mais ma mère avait plutôt peur, très clairement, que ma vie soit beaucoup plus difficile de ce fait.
Ouais.
Et c'était ça en fait. Elle voulait pas me pousser dans cette voie-là, parce qu'elle voulait pas que si jamais j'étais pas vraiment homosexuelle ou bisexuelle ou pansexuelle peu importe,
que j'aille dans ce chemin-là parce que c'est vrai que ça complique beaucoup de choses.
Beh, tu fais une magnifique transition, mais du coup j'ai envie de te demander : est-ce que ça a compliqué beaucoup de choses pour toi ?
Est-ce que tu as connu une,
parce que bon évidemment, tu ne vis pas au Moyen-Orient et tu ne connais pas, voilà, les atrocités que tu as évoquées tout à l'heure, mais est-ce que tu as connu, voilà, une homophobie, du harcèlement
vis-à-vis de ton orientation sexuelle ?
Alors, j'ai eu beaucoup de chance, parce que non, je ne crois pas avoir connu ça. Alors évidemment, si, je me suis déjà fait traiter de gouine, je me suis déjà fait menacer dans la rue, je me suis déjà sentie en totale insécurité,
dans pas mal d'endroits. J'ai déjà
hésité à tenir la main de ma copine dans la rue par exemple,
ce genre de choses-là. Mais il faut dire aussi que j'ai jamais vraiment travaillé en France, que je suis directement allée en Allemagne, notamment à Berlin, là où je vis en ce moment.
Et j'ai jamais eu de problème à l'embauche. J'ai jamais eu de problème outre mesure pour m'intégrer dans la société à cause de ma sexualité, là où je suis.
De la façon dont tu le dis, on a l'impression qu'y a aucune comparaison entre Berlin et la France et que la France, c'est limite l'enfer et qu'à Berlin, tout va bien.
On a l'impression que c'est ça que tu dis.
Non, c'est pas l'enfer du tout, mais c'est vrai que j'ai quand même pas mal de témoignages de copines lesbiennes et de copains gays qui
se font vraiment harceler au travail parce que, bah peut-être que ma copine lesbienne serait trop masculine au goût de ses collègues ou ce genre de choses-là.
Mais je pense que ça dépend aussi des milieux, très clairement. Puis ça dépend des régions aussi, ça dépend des entreprises.
Comme je t'ai dit, Toulon, c'est vraiment pas la région la plus ouverte d'esprit sur ce genre de choses en France.
Ouais, mais justement, si Toulon, c'est pas la région la plus ouverte d'esprit et que, 'fin et que du coup, j'imagine que c'était très intimidant de faire son coming out dans ce contexte-là.
Quelle est la raison qui t'amène à faire ton coming out plutôt que de rester enfermée dans le placard ?
À un moment donné, quand tu es pré-adulte, que tu es en fin d'adolescence et que tu es pré-adulte, tu te dis qu'il va falloir être assez fort pour pouvoir vivre par toi-même.
Et pour pouvoir être assez fort, pour pouvoir vivre par toi-même, ben t'es obligé d'être fier de toi. Enfin moi, c'est en tout cas comme ça que ça s'est passé.
J'avais très très très envie, j'avais un besoin viscéral d'être fière de moi et le fait de cacher qui j'étais vraiment, de cacher les gens que j'aimais alors que c'étaient des gens que je trouvais absolument merveilleux,
pour moi, c'était juste pas concevable en fait.
Donc du coup, je me suis dit : « Bon, je suis comme ça, je ne pense pas être une mauvaise personne, je suis les règles, je ne commets pas de délits, je ne suis pas quelqu'un de méchant, 'fin voilà.
Il se trouve que j'ai cette sexualité-là et ben voilà, ça fait partie de moi et je veux m'assumer en tant qu'adulte.
Et pour pouvoir m'assumer en tant qu'adulte et me construire en tant qu'adulte, et ben j'ai besoin de sentir cette liberté d'être moi-même et d'aimer qui j'aime, de qui je tombe amoureuse.
Et je pense savoir, je pense comprendre que y a plein de gens qui sont encore dans le placard,
Bien sûr.
...et qui n'osent pas le faire. Est-ce que t'aurais, je sais pas, des conseils pour ces gens-là qui n'osent pas, qui sont trop intimidés à l'idée de faire leur coming out ?
Je pense qu'il faut plus avoir peur maintenant parce qu'il faut penser à la, 'fin, ça dépend évidemment de comment on est avec sa famille, etc.
Évidemment, si la personne a 13 ans et est encore obligée de vivre chez ses parents,
et que ses parents sont foncièrement homophobes, bon, il faut quand même réussir à s'entourer un petit peu avant, parce que sinon à la maison, ça peut vite devenir un enfer.
Mais si on commence à être étudiant, si on commence à même être au lycée, si on commence à pouvoir s'autogérer, on va dire, être moins,
avoir moins besoin de ses parents comme référents, à ce moment-là, je pense qu'il faut vraiment pas en faire tout un plat.
Et il faut essayer surtout de rassurer les gens. Parce que, de mon expérience, la plupart du temps, quand on leur dit qu'on n'est pas hétérosexuel,
ils ont peur pour nous, parce qu'ils sont en manque d'informations cruciales.
Et ce qu'il faut réussir à faire en fait, pour faire son coming out, à mon avis, pour faire son coming out sans que ça soit trop
difficile pour tout le monde, c'est apporter surtout énormément de bienveillance et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'amour pour les personnes pour qui on le dit et de pas aller directement dans la confrontation.
Ça sert à rien de mordre directement. Si on arrive vers la personne en disant, bon, tu sais, super énervé, un peu en mode dragon, en disant : « Oui, bon, j'ai quelque chose à t'annoncer, je suis lesbienne ».
Hm hm.
Ben évidemment,
la personne risque de mal réagir en disant : « Ben attends,
c'est bon là, tu m'as rien dit avant ». Et puis va se braquer parce qu'en fait, finalement, nous on a voulu se protéger et puis on s'est braqué en premier et envers quelqu'un de braqué, c'est difficile de ne pas se braquer.
Mais si on y arrive vraiment en douceur, en-- c'est une situation de stress pour la plupart des parents parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas, ils ne savent pas comment réagir et surtout, ils ne se sont pas forcément imaginé ça pour leur enfant.
Donc du coup, il faut vraiment y aller en accompagnant les parents. Donc il faut bien s'instruire soi-même de ce que c'est, comment c'est, etc., ce que ça implique.
Et quand on est vraiment sûr et qu'on a toutes ces informations, pouvoir donner ces informations-là sous une forme
qu'ils vont comprendre, avec des mots qu'ils vont comprendre et qui va les rassurer et il devrait pas y avoir trop de problèmes.
T'évoquais tout à l'heure l'école catholique où tu allais quand tu étais plus petite. Et tu évoquais donc le contexte, voilà, un peu conservateur, passéiste, des idées très hétérocentrées.
J'ai eu l'occasion de m'infiltrer, pour ainsi dire, dans un truc qui s'appelle, c'est les conférences de l'Université de la vie.
Donc c'est un truc organisé par l'Alliance Vita. Donc c'est un peu les copains de la Manif pour tous et toutes ces conneries.
Et j'ai été assez
choqué par la, ouais, à quel point ces gens sont fermés d'esprit, intolérants et... Mais bon, en même temps, c'était intéressant de voir comment ils estimaient que c'était l'autre camp qui était fermé d'esprit et intolérant.
Mais bref, donc j'ai vu ça de mes yeux vu. J'ai pu constater, confirmer qu'effectivement, ces gens-là sont absolument intolérants. Et du coup, je-
Après, ce sont des extrêmes.
Oui.
Clairement pas tous les catholiques sont comme ça, loin de là.
Je dirais que les catholiques les plus fondamentalistes sont comme ça quoi, les plus...
Conservateurs.
Ouais, fondamentalistes.
OK.
En tout cas, c'est mon point de vue. Et du coup, ben du coup, je voulais te demander à toi. Je fais une longue digression pour, je parle beaucoup pour dire très peu de choses, mais pour poser un peu le contexte.
Moi, c'est mon sentiment vis-à-vis de ces communautés religieuses, c'est beaucoup d'intolérance. Toi, tu as été donc dans cette école catholique.
C'est quoi ton rapport aujourd'hui à ces communautés religieuses ? Est-ce que tu les perçois comme étant un petit peu, mais adversaires aux communautés homosexuelles ?
Non.
Non ?
Absolument pas, parce que pour moi, la religion, c'est... Même la religion catholique, alors je ne suis pas du tout pratiquante, je suis à peu près pas croyante maintenant.
J'ai d'ailleurs refusé, au lycée, de faire ma confirmation catholique parce que je me sentais pas en accord avec tout ça.
Mais j'ai aucune haine pour eux et je pense pas qu'il faille être contre, en fait. Je pense que c'est vraiment un très grand manque d'informations, couplé à des traditions, des lectures saintes, et des,
des interprétations des lectures saintes qui sont d'un autre âge, en fait.
Je pense que c'est juste un milieu qui-
Donc là, tu décris l'Église, l'Église catholique avec un grand E. C'est beaucoup de ça, c'est beaucoup de dogmatisme, de vieilles façons de lire les textes. Donc tu dis-
Mais pas partout. En fait, je pense que ce sont vraiment, c'est toujours les extrêmes qu'on voit le plus.
Mais à partir du moment où les extrêmes qu'on voit le plus, c'est le Vatican, c'est quand même difficile de...
Oui, mais le pape a aussi un peu les pieds et poings liés. Il peut pas du jour au lendemain décréter l'homosexualité, c'est cool, allez-y, tout va bien.
Il y a trop d'histoire derrière. Il est aussi représentant de toute cette histoire-là.
Donc il y a une institution, il y a quelque chose qui l'empêche de le faire. Et du coup, quoi, du coup, tu condamnes l'institution ?
Comment est-ce que tu te positionnes par rapport à ça ?
Non, moi, je pense que tout le monde doit être capable et libre de penser ce qu'il veut, à condition qu'il ne marche pas sur les libertés des autres.
C'est pour ça que je suis très en colère, par exemple, pour les gens qui,
que j'ai entendus, notamment lors des débats du mariage pour tous en 2012, 2013 en France, pour,
voilà, tous ces gens qui sont en fait tellement ignorants et tellement dans la haine et non dans l'amour, alors que c'est l'amour que prône normalement la religion,
qu'ils en sont aveuglés, finalement.
Donc, finalement, bon, ils peuvent exister, mais à condition qu'ils n'aillent pas trop loin et qu'ils n'entament pas les libertés, les libertés fondamentales d'exister des gens ou d'avoir des enfants. Voilà.
T'as pas le sentiment que c'est une institution qui tend à créer beaucoup de gens comme ça ?
Non, je pense que chaque personne a son libre arbitre et je pense qu'il y a assez de moyens de réfléchir, de se renseigner.
Il y a énormément de lectures de Bible, par exemple, pour l'Église catholique, qui sont différentes. Je pense que chaque personne est tout à fait assez capable
de rentrer en introspection avec soi-même et, déjà d'une, de comprendre pourquoi ils ont des problèmes avec certaines choses et, de deux, de se remettre en question et de remettre en question leur foi.
Pour moi, la foi, c'est pas juste croire au premier degré tout ce qui est écrit sur un livre. Enfin voilà, sur la Bible, c'est pas du tout...
On devrait tous être plutôt incités à réfléchir par nous-mêmes plus que dire : « Ah ben la religion ou les églises, c'est pas bien parce qu'ils ont des idées pas très très bien. »
Mais tu sais, enfin, ce qui me frappe dans ce que tu dis, c'est que t'es pas du tout dans la victime, t'es pas du tout dans l'adversité par rapport à l'institution qu'est l'Église catholique.
Mais si tu veux, en tant que personne qui n'est pas dans la norme, qui ne rentre pas dans les cases, je sais que je rentrerai à peu près jamais dans les cases finalement à cause de tout ça.
J'ai tellement souffert qu'on me rejette que je n'ai absolument pas envie de rejeter les autres, de faire aux autres ce que moi on me fait parce que je trouve ça tellement injuste que j'ai pas du tout envie de reproduire ça.
Oui, mais Émilie-Marie, si je te présente une institution qui est contre le libre examen, la pensée libre, le fait de s'émanciper des textes et qui est contre l'émancipation-
C'est une dictature ça.
...qui est contre l'émancipation des mœurs, de la sexualité, etc. Ce serait une usine à générer des gens fermés d'esprit, intolérants, etc.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut à la fois dire : « Mais moi, je suis pour la tolérance », en même temps ne pas dire : « Je suis contre cette usine à intolérance ».
Parce que je veux pas être contre des gens. Je pense que des gens qui se retrouvent dans des mouvements, dans des groupuscules comme ça, déjà, je sais que c'est pas du tout la majorité des gens.
Ce sont des exceptions qui sont limite plus exceptionnelles que l'exception que je suis. Donc ça me touche moins.
Et puis en plus de ça, ces gens-là, s'ils ont cette fermeture d'esprit, cette possible haine à l'intérieur d'eux, ben c'est qu'ils sont pas assez évolués pour réagir autrement, c'est qu'ils ont très peur.
Donc je pense que d'aller contre eux, en fait, ça ne va absolument rien résoudre. Ça va juste les braquer encore plus et les conforter encore plus dans leurs idées.
Tandis que si on arrive à trouver un détour pour leur prouver ou leur montrer qu'au moins, ben, déjà, on fait pas de mal à personne, on n'est pas des criminels, on va pas les violer dans leur chambre la nuit.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? À mon avis, il faut trouver un détour, un autre moyen, un autre chemin pour les faire réfléchir.
Je comprends, je comprends très bien.
Mais il faut que le changement, ça vienne d'eux. On peut pas le faire à leur place.
Je comprends très bien que tu dises que t'as pas envie de condamner les gens puisque effectivement, ils sont eux-mêmes victimes d'un truc qui les dépasse.
Mais je, ouais, bon, je te trouve extrêmement tolérante, mais du coup, j'ai envie de transitionner-
C'est mon éducation catholique, c'est pour ça.
OK. J'ai envie de transiter vers une autre question, un sujet que j'ai rapidement évoqué tout à l'heure.
T'as écouté l'épisode 16 de ce délicieux podcast qui s'appelle Septante Minutes Avec, où on parlait de l'homosexualité au Vatican chez les prêtres.
Du coup, en tant que personne LGBT, qu'est-ce que t'en as pensé ? Personne LGBT issue d'une communauté catholique, tout ça, qu'est-ce que t'en as pensé ?
Moi, ça m'étonne pas que beaucoup de prêtres soient homosexuels. Après, d'où ça vient, je ne sais pas du tout.
Je pense pas qu'il y ait vraiment de-- en fait, ça me fait plus de la peine pour ces prêtres qui n'arrivent pas à s'assumer qu'autre chose.
Ça, c'est la première chose. La deuxième chose, je suis toujours frappée de voir à quel point
l'Église a du mal, de mon propre point de vue, hein, ça n'engage absolument que moi, mais, que l'Église a du mal à aller avec son temps.
Y a plein de religions où les prêtres ou l'équivalent peuvent avoir un concubin, une concubine, peuvent avoir des relations sexuelles, peuvent avoir des enfants, etc.
Je vois pas du tout où est le mal là-dedans, finalement. Et ça ne choque pas du tout l'éducation catholique que j'ai-
Ce que je remarque, c'est que tu dis : « Ça te frappe » et à aucun moment t'as envie de dire : « Je trouve ça nul, je condamne ».
Absolument pas. Je suis contre la condamnation. La seule chose que je condamne, c'est la condamnation.
T'es très neutre en fait comme personne.
Alors, je sais pas si je suis neutre, ça, c'est ton point de vue et je l'accepte.
OK.
Non, je sais pas si je suis neutre, mais en fait, je déteste qu'on me juge. Du coup, j'ai pas du tout envie de juger.
Pour moi, être prêtre, je pense que c'est très difficile d'être en accord avec sa foi quand on n'est pas en accord avec soi-même.
Et de ne pas être autorisé finalement à faire plus ou moins ce travail sur soi-même, je trouve ça très très dur en fait.
Moi, j'ai beaucoup de compassion pour ces prêtres-là et pour ces personnes.
OK, ben, j'ai envie de faire un 180 complet puisque bon, on parlait du Vatican qui est, d'après Frédéric Martel, la plus grande communauté gay du monde.
Et j'ai envie de parler de la communauté LGBT au sens large. Tu me disais avant l'interview que y a beaucoup de biphobie et de hétérophobie au sein de la communauté LGBT.
Est-ce que tu peux me parler un petit peu de tout ça ?
Oui, il y a beaucoup de biphobie et beaucoup-- bah, moins d'hétérophobie, je pense, mais il y a aussi de l'hétérophobie, oui, dans la communauté LGBT.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, la phobie, ça ne s'arrête pas du tout à l'hétérosexualité, aux gens hétérosexuels.
Très clairement, les personnes qui ont du mal à comprendre d'autres personnes, c'est plus facile pour elles d'être phobiques.
Et il y a une sorte de retour de bâton, notamment pour l'hétérophobie. En fait, ce sont deux phobies qui ont des causes totalement différentes.
L'hétérophobie, je pense que c'est une phobie qui est réactionnaire à l'homophobie. Un petit peu pour faire
très résumé hein, très grossi, très simplifié : vous nous acceptez pas concrètement, totalement comme nous on est,
nous les homosexuels ou la communauté LGBT en tout cas.
Hmm, eh ben, je vois pas pourquoi nous, on vous accepterait comme vous êtes. Si ça se trouve, vous êtes que des moutons formatés par cette société hétéronormée, voilà.
Ça, c'est l'hétérophobie. Évidemment, moi, ça me hérisse le poil hein. Qu'on soit bien clair, toutes les sortes de discrimination, je ne les cautionne absolument pas.
Mais oui, effectivement, on entend pas mal, enfin, on entend de temps en temps jaser sur les hétérosexuels quand même dans les milieux LGBT.
Pas forcément à raison d'ailleurs. Je trouve que c'est un point qu'on aborde jamais en fait. Mais c'est vrai, il y a plein d'homosexuels qui-- alors c'est pas la majorité hein évidemment,
mais y a des homosexuels qui sont pas tolérants, ce qui est complètement débile à mon avis quand on essaye de prôner la tolérance pour qu'on nous accepte nous de ne pas être tolérants en retour.
Et la biphobie par contre, c'est quelque chose de complètement différent dans le sens où c'est souvent-- on la vit souvent de manière différente si on est un homme ou si on est une femme,
et par la communauté hétérosexuelle, si on peut parler de communauté hétérosexuelle, et par la communauté LGBT où
souvent, moi, je peux parler de, de mon expérience en tant que femme en tout cas, euh, par la, par les, les, les personnes hétérosexuelles, souvent les, les hommes, euh, c'est pas mal vu parce que pour eux, tant qu-,
c'est, c'est pas grave, c'est pas un acte d'amour qui compte vraiment, tu vois.
Et puis en plus de ça, on a vraiment tiré du porno cette sorte de fantasme de deux filles qui vont se chauffer ensemble avant que le mec libérateur avec son gros pénis arrive et puis les libère et leur donne énormément de plaisir.
Enfin bon, évidemment, c'est hyper caricatural, mais disons que deux filles ensemble, ça choque quand même beaucoup moins que deux mecs ensemble.
Et d'ailleurs, très souvent, on m'a dit : « Ah ouais, ah, mais t'es avec une femme en ce moment ? Ah, mais t'es plus souvent avec les femmes ?
Ouais, bah c'est juste parce que t'as pas trouvé la bonne personne ou parce que t'es pas tombée sur le bon mec, qu'ils étaient tous nuls.
» Enfin bon voilà. Par contre, là où ça me dérange encore plus,
c'est dans la communauté LGBT où finalement, on va beaucoup entendre de la part, pour les femmes en tout cas, de la part des lesbiennes, mais c'est pareil pour les hommes, de la part des gays : « Ah, t'es bi ?
Mais non, ça n'existe pas, bi. C'est pas vrai, ça existe pas. T'es soit une hétéro qui est curieuse, et qui du coup a envie, voilà, de temps en temps d'aller avec une femme », parce qu'évidemment, on est trop cool hein, y compris au lit.
Ou alors tu es, et c'est souvent l'hypothèse retenue, une lesbienne qui ne s'assume pas. Ce qui est totalement faux hein, très clairement, ce qui est totalement faux.
Et y a pas la plupart, parce que je pense que maintenant, y a quand même de plus en plus d'informations autour de ça, mais même encore maintenant dans les milieux, j'entends énormément encore : « Ah, t'es bi ?
Ah non, mais moi, je peux pas sortir avec une bi. » Et quand on demande pourquoi, finalement, on te voit pas comme femme, on te voit comme bi, donc potentiellement, personne à risque, infidèle,
qui va forcément avoir besoin, qui ne peut pas se contenter juste d'une femme et qui du coup va forcément aller voir ailleurs, va forcément retourner chez les mecs et du coup tromper sa copine.
Enfin voilà, c'est pas quelqu'un avec qui tu peux t'imaginer vivre sur le long terme, en qui tu puisses avoir confiance, etc.
Alors que c'est complètement différent, évidemment, quand tu es bi, c'est pas-- ou pansexuel hein, c'est pareil dans ce cas-là.
C'est pas que tu as besoin d'un homme et d'une femme dans ta vie, que tu vas jamais être, par exemple, satisfait sexuellement juste par un homme ou juste par une femme.
C'est juste que tu peux potentiellement être attiré et tomber amoureux d'un homme ou d'une femme ou de quelqu'un d'autre qui se détermine pas comme homme ou femme, par exemple dans le cas des pansexuels.
Et donc du coup, y a énormément de biphobie comme ça. Moi, je sais que j'ai pas mal été rejetée. Y avait plusieurs filles sur lesquelles j'avais eu de très gros crush.
J'étais très amourachée, et quand je leur ai expliqué que j'étais bi parce qu'elles se méfient, elles te demandent évidemment.
Quand je leur ai expliqué que j'étais bi super naïvement en pensant que ça poserait pas de problème, parce que ces filles étaient super géniales, on m'a dit : « Ah bah non, mais c'est mort.
Moi, je peux pas sortir avec des bis. Il est hors de question. Ou alors, je vais pas toucher un vagin qui a déjà connu les pénis, c'est pas possible.
» Ce qui est complètement débile, mais on en est vraiment encore là chez, malheureusement, beaucoup trop de lesbiennes à mon goût.
Je suis par exemple sur des groupes Facebook de lesbiennes françaises où du coup, voilà, on poste les nouvelles dans le milieu lesbien, on voit un petit peu ce qui se passe, etc.
Et puis bon, évidemment, il y a pas que des nouvelles hein, il y a aussi plein de gens qui postent des choses d'humour, qui postent des questions, qui postent quand elles ont,
un problème de cœur, quand elles savent pas quoi faire ou quand elles ont juste besoin de parler, etc., d'avoir des avis.
Et, mais vraiment, c'est récurrent. Tu peux être sûr que minimum, allez, deux fois par mois minimum, ce qui est déjà énorme je trouve, il y a quelqu'un sur le même groupe,
qui va poster à chaque fois quelqu'un de différent, qui va poster bi pour ou contre.
Ou alors : « Est-ce que vous pourriez vraiment sortir avec une bi ? » Et la plupart des-- mais vraiment, peut-être 75, 80 % facile des commentaires, c'est : « Ah non, moi, je peux pas.
Ah non, c'est pas possible. Ah non, moi, je peux pas, je veux pas qu'elle me trompe. Ah non, moi, j'aurais trop peur, je ne pourrais pas avoir confiance.
» Voilà. C'est-- et ça, vraiment, on n'en parle pas beaucoup, mais je peux t'assurer qu'on en souffre énormément quand on est dans ce cas-là.
On se fait quand même pas mal rejeter et c'est,
c'est vraiment pas cool de voir qu'on te fait pas confiance parce que tu as déjà trompé ta copine dans le passé ou parce qu'on a raison de pas pouvoir te faire confiance ou en tout cas d'avoir des doutes.
On te fait pas confiance parce qu'on a des préjugés sur une étiquette sexuelle qu'on te met ou que tu donnes, mais qui est juste, qui est valable et qui est pertinente.
Yes.
L'étiquette sexuelle, pas le préjugé, évidemment.
Ouais. Dis, Émilie-Marie, on arrive tout doucement au bout des septante minutes. Juste pour conclure, on avait commencé en disant que tu étais donc française et que tu habitais à Berlin.
Tu es une expat.
Six ans maintenant.
Six ans. Alors, je pose la question un petit peu à l'instinct. Est-ce qu'il y a eu un rapport, un lien entre ton expatriation et l'épanouissement de ta pansexualité ?
Complètement. C'est pas du tout le seul lien. C'est pas du tout la raison, au départ, qui a fait que je suis venue en Allemagne. Mais
à Berlin, je me suis sentie d'un coup libre, beaucoup plus libre d'être qui j'étais vraiment,
de m'habiller comme j'ai envie de m'habiller, de me comporter comme j'ai envie de me comporter, évidemment en respectant les règles de la société, évidemment.
Mais les gens sont beaucoup moins jugeants. Je sens beaucoup moins de,
d'insécurité dans cette ville. Je sens beaucoup moins de jugement sur qui je suis, sur qui j'aime, est-ce que je tiens la main d'une fille, d'un garçon, d'une personne non binaire dans la main, dans la rue.
Y a vraiment aucun problème. Y a beaucoup plus, évidemment, vu que c'est une capitale, beaucoup plus d'endroits où sortir aussi.
Y a beaucoup plus d'informations. Mais y a tout ce climat d'acceptation de l'autre qui fait qu'il y fait particulièrement bon vivre quand on n'est pas forcément dans la norme de la société.
Donc d'une part, l'expatriation, parce que t'es loin de ta famille, tes amis, l'endroit où t'as grandi. Et d'autre part, spécifiquement Berlin, ça te paraît beaucoup plus tolérant que Toulon.
Complètement. Ouais.
OK. Très bien. Donc, on conseille à tous les homosexuels dans le placard de déménager à Berlin, si je comprends bien.
Généralement, c'est là où--
les personnes qui sont pas hétéros et qui ont pas trop trop trop osé ou qui se sentaient pas extrêmement bien là où ils étaient avant, quand ils viennent à Berlin, généralement, ils se lâchent un bon coup et ça-
C'est comme ça que t'as choisi Berlin ?
C'est pas comme ça que j'ai choisi Berlin. Mais c'est vrai qu'on m'avait dit énormément de fois que Berlin, c'était extrêmement cool et qu'on pouvait être qui on voulait et qui on était vraiment et qu'y avait pas toute cette pudeur
qu'on avait en France, toute cette, tous ces petits stress, surtout en tant que fille, du : « Oh, est-ce qu'on va me trouver belle ?
Est-ce que je vais avoir une place dans la société ? Est-ce que je peux m'habiller comme ça ? Est-ce que ça va être OK ? »
Allez.
Voilà, y a absolument pas du tout ça à Berlin. C'est très chill.
Très bien. Mais Émilie-Marie, merci beaucoup pour ces septante minutes. Est-ce que tu veux rajouter quelque chose, un point pour conclure ?
Ça serait bien que tous ceux qui ont des questions, qu'ils soient pansexuels, bisexuels, hétérosexuels, asexuels, homosexuels, peu importe, que les gens qui ont des questions osent les poser.
Y a énormément de gens, moi, je parle de sexualité très simplement avec beaucoup de gens parce que c'est un thème qui me passionne et avec lequel j'ai vraiment, je pense, pas de tabou.
Du coup, les gens aiment parler sexualité avec moi, mais j'ai très souvent ce retour de : « Oh là là, c'est trop bien qu'on puisse parler avec toi, parce que
j'ai déjà rencontré telle et telle personne qui avait tel type de sexualité, mais je savais pas ce que c'était.
J'ai pas osé demander. J'ai cherché sur Google, mais c'est compliqué. Je comprends rien. » Osez, osez très clairement parce que c'est comme ça qu'on fait avancer la société.
Et une personne, si vous êtes pas dans le jugement, même si vous êtes,
peut-être un petit peu maladroit, etc., c'est pas grave parce que nous, même nous, on a été maladroits vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes, finalement, au départ, pour pouvoir,
y voir un petit peu plus clair sur nous-mêmes.
Donc, osez, parlez-en, posez des questions. Je suis à peu près persuadée que dans 99 % des cas, vous allez pas vous prendre un râteau, à condition de poser les questions de manière bienveillante, évidemment.
Mais c'est très important et c'est comme ça que la société évoluera et qu'on pourra tous vivre en harmonie sur ce monde.
Mais c'est magnifique.
Dans ce monde.
Émilie-Marie, merci. Et chers auditeurs, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Bye bye. C'est déjà tout pour ces septante minutes.
Je tiens à remercier encore une fois Émilie-Marie d'avoir accepté mon invitation à la dernière minute. Je le disais dans l'intro, je suis tombé malade.
C'était à cause de mes neveux. Olivier, si tu m'écoutes, je ne te pardonnerai jamais. Je suis tombé malade, mais heureusement, Émilie-Marie était là pour me dépanner.
Et les professeurs Eric Wittaye et Guillaume Agerot ont eu la gentillesse de s'accommoder à cet imprévu. Je les interviewerai d'ici peu.
On parlera en long et en large de ce qu'est l'autisme du point de vue médical, sociétal, féministe et tout et tout. Et je suis impatient de vous proposer ça.
Ce sera dans deux semaines. Et pour ne pas manquer cet épisode, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée ainsi que sur tous les réseaux sociaux.
J'ai mis les liens dans la description. Allez, à dans deux semaines. Salut !